Kiki das kannst du besser napoleontorte
ist doch gar kein
[Musik]
Problem hallo meine Lieben heute gibt es
ein ultra beliebtes Rezept wir machen
Napoleon Schnitten oh mein Gott sind die
lecker ich würde mal sagen gar nicht
lange drumherum Fackeln direkt loslegen
und wir machen jetzt zu allererst den
Teig die ganz genauen Mengenangaben
findet ihr übrigens immer unten in der
Infobox in allen meinen Videos weil dann
könnt ihr euch das einfach screenshotten
einkaufen gehen und das Rezept direkt
nachmachen so Eier gebe ich jetzt hier
in die Rührschüssel meiner
Küchenmaschine das ganze funktioniert
auch mit dem Handrührgerät aber die
Küchenmaschine schlägt jetzt einfach
schön fluffig auf und es geht halt ein
bisschen schneller so da kommt jetzt
eine Prise Salz mit rein und weil das ja
ein Honigkuchen ist kommt der Honig
jetzt hier in unseren Boden und zwar
nehme ich hier diesen Waldhonig am
besten so ein schönen flüssigen den gebe
ich jetzt mit dazu und schlag das schön
3 vi Minuten lang
auf so sieht die Masse jetzt aus richtig
schön dick und weißcemig das hat jetzt
ungefähr 3 Minuten mit der Maschine
gedauert jetzt habe ich hier Natron ihr
könntet alternativ auch Backpulver
nehmen ich schreib es euch ganz genau
noch mal unten rein und Mehl das gebe
ich jetzt hier einmal mit rein ganz grob
verrühren und dann gebe ich es einmal
durch mein Sieb ganz zum Schluss gebe
ich auch noch ein Spritzer Zitronensaft
mit dazu da könnt ihr jetzt auch Essig
nehmen falls ihr den nicht da habt ist
aber ganz wichtig für unser nron damit
das so aktiviert wird quasi genau das
ich jetzt einfach rein und ganz wichtig
nur so kurz wie notwendig verrühren also
jetzt nicht ultra lange rühren sondern
so lange bis sich das Mehl komplett
verbunden
[Musik]
hat wenn ihr euch jetzt unsicher seid
dass irgendwie zu viel Luft
rausgeschlagen wird nimmt einfach euren
Teigschaber und dann einfach noch mal so
ganz ganz sanfte Bewegungen machen dass
auch wirklich alle mehlnester
verarbeitet sind so und jetzt ganz ganz
wichtig das ist jetzt echt Fleißarbeit
muss ich sagen macht euch einfach
nebenbei ein Podcast an hört euch gerne
den Tuesday Talk an das ist nämlich
unser Podcast und dann einfach versucht
so 10 bis 12 Platten herauszubekommen
und zwar nehmen wir uns jetzt einfach
ein Backblech ich habe jetzt hier mein
emaliertes Backblech das hat nicht diese
typische Mulde das ist immer das Problem
bei Backblechen die ihr vom Hersteller
mitbekommt die haben immer diese Mulde
weil sich das bei Hitze verzieht und
dann es ist total blöd ich mag das gar
nicht wenn ich einen neuen Ofen habe
oder auch bei meiner Mama sofort kommen
die backbleäche erstmal raus und ich
nehme hier mein komplett gerades
emaliertes Blech das verlinke ich euch
unten in die Infobox weil da könnt ihr
euch sicher sein dass der Teig wirklich
komplett gleichmäßig gebacken wird und
es sind halt super dünne Böden und da
ist halt wichtig dass sie eben nicht
nicht den Fehler macht und da ja blödes
oder falsches Equipment habt und dadurch
der Teig in der Mitte roh bleibt das W
eigentlich Worst Case so daher hier
einmal schön glatt verstreichen und
darauf achten dass es nicht zu dick
verstreicht man darf das Backpapier ganz
leicht unten drunter sehen und dann
kommt in den vorgeheizten Backofen 170°
Ober und Unterhitze für 5 bis 7 Minuten
und anschließend müssen wir das noch
warm weiter
[Musik]
verarbeiten
den Boden dann wie gesagt sofort weiter
verarbeiten ich nehme mir einfach das
ganze runter auf die Arbeitsfläche und
schneide dann mit einem scharfen Messer
und mit Hilfe meiner teigarte die
Rechtecke aus bei mir sind sie 22 x 16
cm groß und das praktische ist dass ihr
dann wirklich direkt zwei Teige auf
einem Blech habt ich benutze auch
bewusst nicht mein Backrahmen weil wir
brauchen den Überschuss tatsächlich den
ihr hier seht gleich für die Deko bzw
später erst so und das habe ich jetzt
hier auf meinem auskühlgitter einfach
zur Seite legen und dann nehmen wir uns
auch schon wieder das Backblech ich habe
einfach immer zwei im Wechsel ihr könnt
auch immer das gleiche verwenden ihr
braucht keine zwei dann ist es halt nur
sehr heiß D müssture Finger aufpassen so
und wenn ihr auch noch möchtet dass das
Backpapier schön haften bleibt entweder
ein bisschen backtrenpray unten drunter
sprühen oder ihr nehmt euch einfach ein
bisschen was vom Teig und gebt das hier
unten drunter weil es ist total
ärgerlich wenn ihr das verstreicht und
es muss ja wirklich hauchzart
verstrichen werden und dann löst sich
das backpapierständig Mega nervig so und
jetzt mache ich einfach so weiter wie
gesagt am besten immer schön am Ofen
bleiben weil es macht wirklich was aus
also der erste Boden hat bei mir 7inhalb
Minuten gedauert der nächste vielleicht
auch und dann ich weiß es aus Erfahrung
darauf die Böden werden dann immer ein
bisschen schneller gebacken am Ende
landet ihr dann be 5 Minuten daher immer
schön am Ofen bleiben und wie gesagt
hört euch einfach irgendwas an oder
hamser ist ja auch hier mit mir am
chillen kann man sich schön mit seinem
Männer unterhalten nee habe ich kein
Interesse
[Musik]
soll ich noch
[Applaus]
[Musik]
mal die Böden sind jetzt fertig also
wenn ihr wirklich so fünf bis sechs
Bleche rausbekommt wäre es perfekt ich
habe heute fünf rausbekommen beim
letzten Mal waren sechs kommt immer
drauf an wie dick ihr das einstrecht
aber wichtig ist dass ich ja jetzt zehn
Böden habe und das reicht vollkommen und
jetzt machen wir die leckere Creme und
zwar ich habe jetzt hier ein richtig
coolen Trick für Euch das hier ist
gezuckerte Kondensmilch 9% Fett und ihr
könnt daraus dlche delch machen also
Karamellcreme indem ihr das einfach also
ich mache immer gerne das Papier ab weil
das löst sich sowieso und da habe ich
einfach ein Topf voll Wasser aufgekocht
und da gebe ich diese Konserve jetzt
einfach rein und das bereite ich immer
schon vorher zu also Tage vorher oder
wenn ich gerade mal Zeit habe und das
ganze verwandelt sich jetzt in 3 Stunden
eben zu Karamellcreme also das ganze dre
Stunden hier drin lassen immer wieder
Wasser nachgßen und auch den Deckel
drauf machen und dann das habe ich schon
vorbereitet habt ihr als Ergebnis so
also vorher ist die kondensmch richtig
weiß und dann wird sie schön braun
unsere Creme besteht aus nur zwei
Zutaten ein mal unsere Karamellcreme
also delche del und saure Sahne wenn ihr
jetzt keine saure Sahne da hab würde
auch Creme fresch funktionieren und das
ganze wird einfach nur zusammen verrührt
übrigens fertige dulsche del also
karamellisierte Kondensmilch findet ihr
auch bei Kaufland aber ich fand es als
Trick einfach ganz cool euch das so mal
zu zeigen so einfach mit dazueben
zusammenrühren und dann zeige ich euch
wie ihr die Torte
[Musik]
schichtet so die Creme ist auch fertig
gerührt wenn sie zu flüssig sein sollte
dann einfach Sahnefest mit reingeben
aber in den meisten Fällen braucht ihr
das nicht ihr müsst auch nicht zu viel
rühren weil dadurch wird's halt auch
noch mal flüssiger und jetzt wird
geschichtet ich nehme jetzt den ersten
Boden habe jetzt hier meine drehbare
Tortenplatte mit einer Schieferplatte
oben drauf weil das passt jetzt einfach
perfekt zum Servieren und jetzt
schichtet ihr folgendermaßen immer
erstmal ein bisschen Zuckersirup auf die
Platte streichen sollte in der
Zwischenzeit auch schon ausgekühlt sein
und dann ein bisschen Creme darauf geben
und und dann macht ihr immer so weiter
bis ihr ganz oben angekommen seid und
ganz am Ende wird die Torte dann auch
noch komplett mit der Creme
[Musik]
eingestrichen jetzt dürft ihr euch nicht
wundern es ist alles noch so ein
bisschen weich also die Creme ist sehr
weich die Platten sind aber noch hart
die ganze Magie passiert während der
Kühlzeit daher auch ganz ganz wichtig
dass ihr die einhaltet aber ich
finalisiere das jetzt noch mal indem ich
hier diese
kuchenbodenreste einmal in mein Mixer
gebe und dann kommen da auch noch
walnuskerne mit dazu das passt
geschmacklich so gut vertraut mir dann
Schredder ich das und gebe das einmal
rundhum auf den ganzen Kuchen und dann
bitte die Kühlzeit beachten ich weiß ihr
werdet mich jetzt Tassen aber schon so 8
Stunden oder halt über Nacht und daher
sehen wir uns morgen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wieder
[Musik]
gerade ist meine cy
gerade der Kuchen konnte richtig gut
durchziehen es ist super weich habt ihr
beim Anschnitt wahrscheinlich gerade
gesehen ja hams ich bin mal gespannt auf
deine Meinung probier gerne mal ich
schneide in der Zwischenzeit mal das
Original an ach so ich da das von dir ne
we ich wollte halt gerne wissen wie man
die Schichten dazwichen Verpackung das
sieht eher aus wie das hier ja es sieht
bei mir wirklich aus wie auf der
Verpackung ne ja aber das soll diese
Krümel darstellen die eigentlich hier
sind also diese festen Nüsse genau also
was ich schon direkt sagen kann ist
meine Krümel oben drüber eiglich sind
dicker als hier was ist Nüsse nein das
ist der Rest vom Teig und
Walnüsse aber meine sind viel viel
dicker ausgefallen als hier beim
Original das muss ich dazu sagen ich mag
das ja auch was zum Beißen zu haben ne
aber auch die Schichten sind heftig aus
aber ich muss echt sagen ich habe mich
so an meinem Napoleon mit dwig mal Lenk
Rezept gehalten und hier sieht es mir
wirklich nach Blätterteig aus ich glaube
hier wurde einfach ein ganz anderer Teig
Ben Punkt Abzug daavon get ich bin
sicher des se wietig die külzeit ist so
hab s ich w mal sagen nicht lang
schnacken Kopf in Nacken und D mit
probier guck mal wie die Gabel da
durchgleitet das ist der Hammer oh
richtig lecker richtig lecker Bo das mir
echt lecker das ist auch mal was ganz
anderes es ist was ganz anderes auch vom
vom Mundgefühl her ne nicht das was man
so kenn schmeck das auch so den schmeckt
man gut raus ne was hast das für ein
Teig jetzt gemacht ich habe so ein
honigteig gemacht aber ich finde es ist
einfach mal ein ganz ganz ganz anderes
ganz anderes Gefühl von Torte ganz
anders so weich auch richtig weil guck
wie man da durchgleitet aber die
Schichten das waron ver anstrengend ne
was heißt anstrengend ganz ehrlich nein
eigentlich nicht weil man hat immer zwei
auf einmal gebanken das ist eigentlich
voll der gamechanger also richtig cool
müsst ihr unbedingt nachbacken bin der
festen Überzeugung dass ihr was verpasst
wenn ihr das nicht nachmacht also ich
finde es hat Diskussion al Napoleon
medov Malenka schreibt mir in die
Kommentare was ihr davon haltet war
französis herrcher schreibt mir gerne
was ihr davon haltet ich bin super
gespannt freue mich auf weitere
Vorschläge was ich dann beim nächsten
mal nachmachen soll und eure Bewertung
wie ist deine Bewertung ja vol lecker
ehrlich richtig lecker also richtig fris
lecker
Honig ich auch hammer Leute von punktech
unbedingt nach und schaltet auch beim
nächsten Mal wieder ein bis bald
[Musik]
tschüss